[Music]
do you guys remember that one time you
covered an article
about kung fu vagina what
explain this wait i know this i remember
the penis one
oh we did the penis one did we didn't do
the vagina one where women can like
strengthen their [ __ ] oh that's kegels
right teagles yeah
cheetos but like weighted kegels too
like they put oh i didn't know it was
kung fu but i remember
that where they used like weights for
their yeah yeah there's like
weightlifting for
vaginas they can pull cars and stuff
like that yeah
[Music]
well the person that we're saying
they can pull cars with it it's like a
one-man one-woman show have you guys
ever seen that probably
i've seen guys pull trains but they're
not sex yeah see same thing
it doesn't seem like a very lady thing
to do to always like
do random [ __ ] with their [ __ ] like
it's like a guy [ __ ] to like yo
let's [ __ ] have a com like
competition
healthy for your bladder control when
you're older yeah see oh
so maybe more women should try to pull a
truck with their [ __ ] yeah we should
strive for that women
don't start there but work your way up
no true
no it's all about progressions and
regressions just kidding
i'll watch it in our back jakey
it's like we're bringing jk party back
how would you pull the truck would you
pull the truck this way
or this way that seems better right
yeah which way you go you face that way
so you use your glutes and your hands to
you know wait if it's this way
i already got a great head start yeah
but the glutes are bigger muscles
gotta have a hook yeah so it goes in
like this and she walks over
and then i just go along with it yeah
that's on patreon right oh my so kung fu
i'm kung fu kracha
all right so the founder of this type of
like uh i guess discipline her name
is kim akami kim kochi
that's better tiff you're on fire right
now dude fire
point is there is a music video oh that
has been produced to promote her
discipline what wait so is like strong
vagina
so it's like oh kim and nami that's her
name it's right here in the beginning of
the the music video but i will play a
portion of the music video for you and
now you tell me
is that her real name uh probably not i
hope not she's a white lady
oh
it's already started off amazing
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god do you feel your
skin crawl already yo what though
what that's pretty cool
[Music]
[Applause]
it was just a really bad comedy job get
it oh yeah it's not like a bit
well how much is the program
[Laughter]
and how can you do a co-promotion with
barbara bernier yeah
wait so it really like i don't know i'm
confused is she a musical artist
a comedian i think she's promoting her
gym vagina are
like kung fu i don't get it she is she's
the founder of
uh let me find it kegel size when we did
the jk news this is her
yeah that's why i was confused because
like it was a white lady
and then we did a jk news about her in
her whole gym and method
oh you she was dead so then when uh you
talked about it
i thought it was like a chinese lady
doing actual vagina kung fu
right so she's a sex and relationship
coach and she teaches vaginal weight
lifting and that's her business that's
three things then sex relations approach
and a vaginal weightlifting coach
yeah it seems like an overall lifestyle
like you know it's a pro
female health and stuff like that like
health nutrition
these are all great questions i do not
know if she's licensed or not
but the bigger part of the story is the
[ __ ] music video and the fact that
she hired two singers
who i don't even they don't even really
mention their names i wouldn't even want
to be mentioned
if i was a part of this production she
made this music video to promote her
business
and now the asian american community has
sounded off on it
obviously it is [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] i
bet like the same dudes that made the
rebecca black
music video made hers remember that but
you would think you would learn a thing
or two about
you know appropriating along the way
unless it's just
it really i think we've had the
conversation we've had the conversation
about how some people don't see
that as she she doesn't see that at all
as that she did something wrong
usually they're usually quiet
that's the usual culprit usually
persuasion quiet she's probably like
we're just uh making the the song for
like everyone wants kung fu fighting the
parody
and whatever she's uh she's there
where's she from
you can't tell them you can't tell that
i'm
she did this in l.a so here's the thing
though like if you do that it has to be
really good though
right right but that is i mean it was
pretty good production
i mean but even if it is
does she marry what if she has a little
tokyo zip code
if she marries an asian guy she gets
some street cred she gets some points no
i mean like if she's if that's her legal
name because of marriage then we can't
really
yeah we gotta okay so what's the rules
behind this like
if she's with the asian dude and he's
like yo check it out that's my wife
she's a little crazy but i gave her the
permission
we'll be like ah [ __ ] you gave her the
[ __ ] asian card all right [ __ ] it
then
whatever damn she's [ __ ] but what
about the other girls though i think
it's the art so if she was really
like let's say uh expert in kung fu
and a and specialized vagina and kung fu
then she might have a little bit but she
invented her own
she invented her own [ __ ] and now is
using the asian culture
to market comedy yeah like that's right
who sings the original song not that
girl just no out of curiosity
what's an original song that's the only
reason
i'm just i'm just wondering right now
who sings that carl
yeah it's a black guy right yes
everybody wants kung fu fighting
carl douglas looks like
damn catch was fast as lot
boy carl douglas did it i guess you know
kim and nami could do it right
there was a period where there's a lot
of black martial arts movies though too
but this made asians cool yeah
it wasn't like at the time yeah he
wasn't making
he was like oh man kung fu movies was
the [ __ ] bro
yeah everybody was watching homage to
the culture
she's parroting it there we go that's
right so sex
lift vagina lift weightlifting aside how
would you pay homage to
asian culture if not if you're not asian
but she doesn't need to pay homage
because the art she's
doing yeah it has nothing to do with
truth yeah it's not true
it's not an ancient asian art of vagina
clinging
and if you want to know what that is
sign up for my program
but second this is the corniest [ __ ]
i've ever seen yeah
if she was on a table and she was
shooting ping pongs out of her [ __ ] and
there was a chinese olympic team
ping-pong player going like this and
[ __ ]
that would have been a way better
[ __ ] missing because she did shoot a
picture of her [ __ ]
and then it makes me feel weird seeing
the the like the asian lady
be like a screenshot no i was trying to
i was trying to add more media i'm
trying to add ping pong to carl does
this for that casey
no no no no no no we were watching
what is she doing i just snitched on
casey i'm sorry
oh a screenshot from the video that's
funny
okay no but yeah like the asian ladies
though like they she hired
this is kim mono this is
in there
they lose their asian card this is just
not good though yoga girl wasn't she
asian
uh well she got all different types of
colors she got white black she covered
her bases
um yeah she she was very small she's
included diversity let's
let's cancel the asian girls in here
let's no i don't want to go
you can't be a part of the asian group
no more see you should hit a quarter i
gotta i gotta show you the wrap part
there's a wrap oh there's a wrap part
you guys are a big fan of rap i love hip
hop
means we accept the numbers energy comes
from within
your orgasm
i i feel like i'm about to vomit this
video is way too long about goosebumps
i paid for this like how much money went
into
they they did like two days of shooting
you know like this took this six
days there are people that are probably
going to go
and sign up for this [ __ ] because how
like now they're interested because it
probably works it's three on one it's
sex relationship
and vagina weightlifting see the service
isn't the issue
it's just how whacked this video yeah
like that's not a marketing ploy
giggles yeah do your giggles bro come on
man i ain't mad at you why you gotta
make some asian [ __ ] so lame but it's
just also not
tacky yeah and let me ask you this how
come asian stuff
like this keeps happening whereas like
if it was another
ethnic minority there's generally more
of an
uproar is there you know like how come
this stuff keeps happening yeah
it kind of just fizzles out and it
happens
and all these black guys came out and
they had like fried chicken and [ __ ]
dude they'll be so
[ __ ] cancelled right now very
canceled they're but yeah they they like
they do stupid asian [ __ ] like this and
then like
they're not canceled what the [ __ ] dude
we gotta it's not fair man
i don't know if we're maybe it's
cultural but i don't feel like we have
an outrage enough
but then also i think for us we also
don't know if
outrage is like our go-to or maybe we're
just so
troubleshooting it's like um you know
like
i think the asian way it's not so much
about expressing the emotion
it's like you wanna fix the problem so i
think the asian way might be like
oh okay i know i need to call to cancel
this [ __ ] so instead of like out
on the streets
instead of going on the streets like
take the [ __ ] down
it's like but what made you want any
pictures i was yeah i was gonna
say but do you okay does anybody
identify
with the stuff in this video to where
you're offended by what they're doing or
do you see it as
how it's it's literally just a mockery
of what people
think chinese culture is that's i think
she hit it right on the [ __ ] head
because it's like
this is a chinese takeout yeah like like
it's worse than panda express yeah do
you know what i'm saying we are not this
you're not as an asian american we are
not this it's not directly
it's a mockery of us
that's a mockery of whatever they think
it is but if you know what it is it's
it reminds us of hey chinese stupid
that's what we think when we see that
exactly
are you [ __ ] you're were you born in
the [ __ ] 50s or what you know because
this is like the hackiest dumbest [ __ ]
like
yeah and that is also like just more
upsetting than the asian part like yeah
obviously it's
she took it to the nth degree but it's
also like
this is awful like terrible i've seen
when people have worn traditional
attire incorrectly and people get
enraged and then you see people having
to make apologies
and really that's something that affects
me no but but i've seen more
uproar over certain things like that to
where people
are misusing actual sacred
you know things to the culture this
looks like we're even just using them
correctly
but because you're not the right
ethnicity using them you can't use it
you know what though i'm glad she didn't
put a jade boot up or [ __ ] and say like
oh if that would have popped out oh
they have jade yoni thingies uh [ __ ]
balls or whatever they stones what do
they call them yoni
stones it's that it's like weights for
your vagina
oh oh wait is she making fun of it no no
i'm saying that that does exist
jade stones to the cable
[Laughter]
but that was like you know to the point
is it because
so many people look at them like you're
[ __ ] dumb if you think that's what we
actually are like
and imagine you're really trying to sell
your business and that's how you promote
it
bro imagine barbell did some [ __ ] like
that nobody would go to barbell
i would joe would but like that's just
because he's your homie
it's not because that video was so dope
he's like i want to do this part that
annoys me
like so much is the mockery part like
that
it could have been any other ethnicity
with any other ethnicity and i'm just
like it's the same noise like
why like [ __ ] what if they love it so
much they really love asian but you can
tell the
mockery tone like the intention is like
i'm making fun of this
yo this reminds me of when el ella tran
ha
made the she was the girl for that music
video asian girls oh yeah and she got
cancelled like
[ __ ] crazy and the whole band was
like no we're trying to [ __ ] pay
homage to asian girls but the whole
music video
was a horrible wannabe parody that just
made fun of asians so we do
cancel people yeah there was this one
white chick from like orange county
she's done that she did it see you later
she did a song about like ninjas or some
[ __ ] like i don't want
like want to be a ninja or something and
then she was interviewed by andrew
santino
and bobby lee and they just [ __ ] on her
her video was way worse
because she was like no like i'm just
trying to be
like i'm showing homage to asian culture
or some [ __ ] yeah but it's like
what are you talking about you're
talking about being a ninja and like
crawling around and it's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
but they were trying to talk to her like
yeah can't you see how this can be
offensive
a little bit no no it's a i watch comedy
karate kid
okay look okay i watch a lot of brewstee
movies i know a thing or two about asian
culture
this is just clearly awful though yeah
no this is trash and
everybody in it thinks that it's okay
[Music]
yeah
you